on le sait quand on est fan on est prêt
à tout pour obtenir quelque chose
d'exclusif de notre star si les
autographes ou autres celles ci sont de
rigueur pour ceux qui ont la chance de
croiser en vrai ce qu'ils admirent des
sites proposent aujourd'hui le graal une
vidéo exclusive de votre célébrité
préférée vous l'aurez compris il s'agit
d'un service payant une activité pour le
moins lucrative initié en 2016 par le
site américain caméo le principe payer
pour que votre star vous envoie un
message personnalisé en vidéo
si aux etats-unis cette pratique est
courante rares sont les stars françaises
qui ont aujourd'hui recours à ces
applications pourtant on retrouve sur
caméo le nom du tennisman jo-wilfried
tsonga il vous en coûtera 123 euros pour
obtenir un message du joueur vous
souhaitons par exemple un joyeux
anniversaire
amoureux les happy to which you de
postes oddo reste en revanche si vous
souhaitez que caitlin jenner vous
félicite pour votre brevet blanc il
faudra casser votre tirelire pour
débourser les 2050 euros demandés si
vous n'avez pas de quoi payer une vidéo
vous pouvez toujours obtenir un
autographe de votre star sans vous
déplacer le site all autographes propose
à la vente des autographes de stars même
décédée alors signature authentique ou
gribouillages d'un stagiaire a ouvert
les dames gare aux arnaques
enfin la des sites les plus connus pour
ce type de service s'appelle only fans
un réseau social où il faut payer pour
s'abonner au profil de personnalité et
obtenir un contenu exclusif
si ce site est beaucoup utilisé pour des
publications à caractère sexuel
la star car diby a décidé de s'y
inscrire et publie régulièrement des
photos sexy d'elle un business payant
puisqu'elle a déclaré touché 8 millions
d'euros par mois grâce à cette page
alors star a brand comprenez vous
l'engouement des fans pour ses
applications c'est ce que je voulais
choqué parce que franchement des fadas
les neet le conquois
c'est un service qui leur permet de
l'approché nord mais ses préférées bien
sûr après je trouve ça très spécial de
monnayer un autographe
il faut pas faire payer un autographe je
crois qu'on doit beaucoup aux gens qui
nous suivent les réseaux sociaux etc
qu'on vende quelque chose comme quelqu
un est décédé je peux comprendre mais
qu'on fasse payer un autographe ou une
vidéo
ces arnaques et le fan c'est fait pour
moi c'est une escroquerie sims et moi on
m'a proposé mois plusieurs fois si on
voulait faire il ya des signatures en
parler moi je trouve ça scandaleux
observe mac et les fans c'est pas bien
surpris mais je suis totalement contre
ce genre de sites
on m'a proposé plusieurs fois de mettre
toutes mes célébrités il y en a certes
une qui ils sont toujours pas dans mon
agence mais qui sont moi je trouve ça
scandaleux
j'ai entendu des revenus à vingt trente
mille euros par mois qu'ils arrivent à
se faire en mettant des photos avec le
cul cul un peu à l'air ils mettent ce
qu'ils veulent mais en fait c'est que il
donne du contenu beaucoup plus sexy que
c'est pas le sien en dc pas le site
sillonnent l'île fans et autres biens
d'autres sites ça devient ça devient
récurrent
moi je trouve qu'aujourd'hui real et
placement produit sur les réseaux on
vend des produits on n'oblige personne à
les acheter c'est du produit c'est des
trucs qu'on les gens ont envie d'acheter
mais par contre vendre une dédicace un
petit message tout comme ça je trouve ça
juste dégueulasse que magali s'est fait
éjecter du business je te conseille
d'être aussi comment dit comment il a
dit je conseille vraiment d'y aller je
te jure rebond des noms mais maillot
limoux à dire ça de dire ça à te dire
que je veux tu veux mais dis moi mais
c'est très fort bien d'argent on m'a
proposé pour faire ça qu'on centaines de
milliers d'euros pour ton information
ce serait bien de faire ça si l'argent
récolté à l'épargné aux restos du coeur
alors mes rêves il est rond pour penser
alors moi je suis pas choqué en soit je
me dis que ça re re on n'est pas obligé
d'acheter ces autos corts et vidéo c'est
que après ils créent une offre en fait
ferrer pour les neuf sages aucun groupe
me convenait bien
et bien sûr un peu d'aller verser un peu
moins de bonheur sur votre mariage on en
fait on ait tous aujourd'hui mais c'est
un homme qu'on doit faire envers nos
draps 28 et c'est grâce aux gens qu'on
bouffe mais oui c'est à eux de leur
faire payer les gens qui regardent nous
font vivre et en plus on va leur
demander de l'argent à terre c'est pas
bien c'est le minimum qu'on l'entend
excusez moi si vous voulez faire plaisir
à une cousine qui adore jennifer lopez
vous n'avez pas les coordonnées de
jennifer lopez vous êtes bien obligés de
payer 75% pour l'artiste et 25% mais non
moi je trop j'aurais adoré faire appel à
ça quand j'étais jeune je suis désolé ça
ne me choque pas ce qui me choque c'est
que magali soit choqué avec voilà ce que
après quoi après 41 artistes de dire bon
anniversaire plaisait à bout tu as pensé
quoi les influences aboudi dégueulasse
pour sa gelée il ya une différence entre
le placement de produit et ça lui passe
un produit tu vois un produit plus beau
depuis un produit tu vas te servir à ton
coaching with mais c'est prendre enfin
pensez à utiliser sensibilité des champs
à bram et ça je trouve ça pas gentil
d'entendre au contraire daniel au 21e
siècle une star connue sur les réseaux a
la possibilité de faire du placement
produit qui sont pas forcément bien
faire ça tu peux pas vivre suffisamment
sur les placements de produits t'as pas
besoin de vendre un autographe et sait
pas où est ce que tu dis tu peux pas me
dire l'hôpital et sa fille c'est le mot
excuse moi c'est toujours des cons les
produits je suis déjà les acquis sont
pleines les produite mais parfois c'est
de la merde à ça fait plaisir
[Musique]
il est parfois d'escroquerie général
mais ça m'a choqué beaucoup de sites
est ce que moi j'ai soif je rêve mais
les procès grenet il est beaucoup de
choses donc tu peux pas dire ça
aujourd'hui c'est jouer sa qualité s'en
vont la tension monte
[Musique]